hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and right now I am in
Vancouver Canada which is a place I've
wanted to go forever but specifically
visiting see it the coalition I'm here
to check out Gears of War for
single-player today and then multi-play
out tomorrow so it's gonna be two days
of tons of playing gears but I also
thought that I would kind of show you
guys around the city and explore a bunch
so this is my Vancouver slash Giza
before blog welcome
so we made it to this giant room of
screens and people playing video games
this is Sean he walks with me in IGN and
are you really excited Phileas well
phocion absolutely love gears haven't
played in a really long time looking
forward to seeing what they got the
store for us yes so we're gonna play
like two hours with a single plane out
and I'll let you know what I think when
we finished let's do it
so we just finished day one playing like
2-3 hours of the single play oh it's
really cool there's a lot of stuff that
was really surprising to me that they
added in like a lot of different weather
effects now we're gonna go explore
Vancouver and I will maybe like talk a
little bit more in detail about how I
felt about it when I get back to the
hotel room but it's like 6:00 p.m. and
still really sunny outside so
so I've just made it back to the hotel
room wandered around the city for a
little bit going to charge my phone and
then head out for dinner somewhere but
you just want to say like if there's
anything I notice about this city it's
that you can see it's like incredibly
modern in architecture I don't know how
old Vancouver is but it looks really
really young especially compared to San
Francisco it's kind of like Sydney in a
way but it's really clean all the
streets are really spaced apart and the
architecture is awesome I really really
like it here so far
god damn when I'm tired I really just
want to take a nap right now it's like
nearing 7:00 and I have to get up like
full thottie for my flight this morning
because it's technically an
international flight but I only came to
the room to drop my bag off and then go
explore so I'm gonna go do it I'm just
going to do it very tired Lee
so I made it back to the hotel again
still very tired we went to get dinner
at an Italian place cold ill Nino I
think it was it was incredibly good but
before I had to sleep for an even bigger
day tomorrow I thought I would give you
a couple of very quick impressions on
what I played of the give a full
single-player campaign today few hours
that we played had a ton of enemy
variety I don't know what the alien kind
of species is and I wonder if they are a
product of locust or related to locusts
somehow like I mentioned before the
weather effects are really really cool
there's lightning that you have to avoid
and storms which make debris go
everywhere and it was also like a nice
kasi quench that was kind of like the
Madagascar bit and uncharted for you
just racing and avoiding things and
trying to shoot at the same time which I
never expected to have any kids a wall
game and that was super fun for now I'm
going to bed I will see you guys
tomorrow morning we're gonna check out
multiplayer and hold mode tomorrow can't
wait good night
good morning you fantastic people I just
woke up and right now the sunrise that I
can see is crazy beautiful
got a good sleep not feeling too tired
right now
she says yawning okay just did a crappy
hotel room walk out and then put some
makeup on my crappy fifteen minute walk
out consisted of planks push-ups and
tricep dips and basically when I'm
traveling I try and do things that I
don't necessarily need a weight fall and
basically I just do a huge number of
reps we do whatever we can to get by
so we have just arrived at the coalition
for day two back in this giant room of
Xbox one SS and screens and we're about
to play a bunch of multiplayer playing
three months to start with and then
gonna have lunch and jump into horde
which I am the most excited about after
playing a tiny bit of it at PAX West
we are jumping in a horde mode we have
our team of five we all have different
classes I'm a soldier
basically the different classes start
out with different loadouts and also you
get like Cod's in hole 3.0 meaning that
they have different bosses kinda the
soldier skill the one that I have right
now the first one is 60%
reload bonuses for an active reload so
that's awesome we're gonna try really
really hard to get to weigh 50 in theory
would be some of the best people in the
world to get to wait 15 it could take
about two hours of straight plane gives
quad mode for us to actually get this
done this often fly out tomorrow but I
really hope we get there
wish me luck one way
killing it weighed 58 [ __ ]
[ __ ] is already very real someone's
gonna sniper out here oh no [ __ ]
okay we've been playing for an hour and
a half we just cleared wave 30 we're on
31 we've got two mobile sites to go
until we get to 50 it was a nice break
it's getting very intense here so let's
see if we can get to that 50 in the next
hour or so
Oh what uh how did that happen nope
Thank You Bonnie I'm gonna build you a
churro okay we're all gonna bleed all
right I'll get you back out first ones
free holy crap all right first round
back in was a little rough so it took
like four hours of playing but we
finally ended up doing it had a lot of
trouble from wavez 30 to 40 because some
of the people who are not two originally
left and then all the people came back
in and I really screwed us up and then
the original team swapped back in but
Shawn and I are the first people in the
world outside of the coalition to finish
Gears of War 4 horde mode so I'm really
tired but it was very very fun and I'm
very proud of us
so I'm now in the back of the cab about
5:00 a.m. on the way to the airport last
night after we finished horde I had a
couple of interviews with multiplayer
specific tabs and then a whole big group
of us went on to dinner but my phone was
near dead so he didn't capture any of
that good stuff but to give you guys
some brief final thoughts on what I
thought of gives before I mean I'm just
crazy excited about it the new
multiplayer mode escalation is just so
competitive and that's exactly what I
want out of that multiplayer and also
yeah horde was a serious challenge I'm
so proud of us for getting through it I
will be covering the last two days for
GN so I will link you guys to stuff that
I make all right or whatever in the
description below if you want to check
that out and Vancouver has been
absolutely beautiful it's been amazing
whether it's such a clean pristine city
I really really like Canada that is it
for me today everyone I will see you
guys next time bye